ما هو سقف الدين الامريكي
سقف الدين هو الحد الاقصى للمبلغ الذي
يمكن للحكومه الامريكيه اقتراض لسداد
التزاماتها الماليه وفق الميزانيه
كمدفوعات تذهب معظم الاموال لدعم برامج
انفاق تشكل ما يقرب من نصف الميزانيه
كالضمان الاجتماعي والرعايه الطبيه ثم
يستحوذ الانفاق العسكري على الجزء الاكبر
الولايات المتحده تنفق اكثر مما تحصل عليه
فتلجا الى الاقتراض وللاستدانه تصدر وزاره
الخزانه اوراق ماليه كالسندات الحكوميه
والتي تسدد قيمتها اضافه الفوائد بمجرد
وصول الحكومه الى الحد الاقصى لا تستطيع
وزاره الخزانه اصدار المزيد من السندات
الكونجرس هو الجهه المسؤوله عن رفع سقف
الدين والذي تجاوز الان
31.4 ترليون دولار في حال تخلف الولايات
المتحده عن سداد ديونها لن تكون الحكومه
قادره على دفع رواتب الموظفين الحكوميين
وستتوقف دفعات الضمان الاجتماعي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات